you
oh i'm on camera hey i didn't even know
i was live i'm glad i was watching the
stream on um
that i was watching the stream on my
phone glad i didn't say nothing crazy
hey eddie we live now i don't know if
you know that
yeah i don't know
um
i i i'm just going with it man i'm going
with it right now yeah it just went like
until i'm going with it and i think the
stream i think the youtube stream is
going to be connected from us moving and
moving the movement again i think it's
going to be all connected because like i
said so i have not had to stream up and
just figure that
it's just
the part that just annoys me is just
like i think this should be fun like i
don't see any issues going on
uh let me put this in the other one
all right hold on let me i'll ask the
chat
there we go
now let me death this one
i'm not gonna
no not i'm gonna debt the one that we
just did
just keep the stream labs one
okay all right let's try this again man
let's try this again all right so
i don't know if you guys want to try to
do you guys want to try to do the
i did have a super chat i can't remember
what it was i was going to read it
i apologize guys like
usually i the issues never happen with
me when it comes to it because you i do
a lot of pre-existing stuff but for some
reason it you know it's it's it's it's
been it's been it's been rough out here
man so you guys just tell me how it goes
you know i got your stuff christopher i
got your stuff uh don't don't worry
we're gonna say i'm hoping that
everything goes good uh i definitely
apologize to a hustle and
uh shitty for you know having to switch
no worries
shinny tell the people who you are again
because i'm not making another i'm not
stitching them together so we're going
to just briefly do another intro because
we want people to know who's on the park
[Laughter]
so hopefully we can get my name right
shawnee
okay
i it's just like when it comes to me i
could barely speak english so any name
that's not like an english like uh young
as because i always have a hard time
with it like that's why when it comes
like especially the japanese name that's
that's just a lost cause to me
like if i if you're not i'm not reading
japanese names very very good but uh so
you know so you know are you a permanent
panel member over there now on guys
uh no not permanent it's still a asa and
gaz are the permanent ones and then i
just come in like safe right he comes in
every now and then um so i'd be coming
in every now and then
all right so um sorry about every that
uh it is in the chat so uh hustles
continue your kingdom heart slander
uh it's not even slander i'm really
enjoying it um like i said i will have a
video hopefully that video will be done
by friday about three hours and i'm
really enjoying the game in the next
live stream that i'll be doing should be
later on that friday night hopefully
around
five six ish o'clock i'm trying to like
really
work out a schedule because streaming is
it's not the easiest thing to do it's
just i got to make sure that i'm
available for it um it's fun though it's
fun and i see why a lot of people kind
of like fell in love with the franchise
with the series and whatnot it's dope to
see
mickey mouse and and well not mickey
mouse it's dope to see donald and goofy
and pluto and
and all of them and it's good to see
them like in in like a different light i
want to say more mature life but it's
just dope to see that that's fully voice
acted nintendo y'all can learn something
from that um get some voice voice actor
neo games it's cool though this is cool
and i'm having a good time and i can't
like wait to release like the video on
it so
i'm having a great time with that and
you know but i i want to like talk you
know to the hockey um i i saw you all i
normally see you in like the lp chats
like all the time
i had no clue that you like did like the
podcasting thing whatsoever i didn't
know you made content yeah how long have
you been making content
oh gosh uh not too too long it's this
year so um
so yeah like beginning of the year is
when i think i started putting out some
videos
and um and then yeah just sort of like
from the super chats to
into podcasting it's sort of escalated
pretty fast
okay so you came straight out the
comments section
literally
i like that that's actually
straight out the comments section
like a lot of us have done man
so wait do you have a youtube channel
and if so
like what do you cover on there like
what's the the you know
yeah i try to look at like analyzing the
industry instead of uh your current news
so i generally don't do the new stuff
there's plenty of good podcasters doing
that already
so i'm trying to think of things like uh
you know um
should ubisoft be bought is that a good
thing or not um and then like things
like uh are are is the drive to get
better graphics is that a good idea or a
bad idea right as we keep making the
games better like attic you were saying
like you want the gameplay right now i'm
with you on that i'd i'd rather have the
game and have tight gameplay than have
it like every like leaf on a tree is
working perfectly i don't care i'm not
looking at the tree i'm looking at the
game i want to play the game right and
so like but that's what they pay
attention to that's why it takes like
eight years to get a game now and i'd
rather just have the game give me the
game in a two to three year mark and you
know so stuff like that so those are
kind of my uh my videos
um so yeah
okay good that's good to go
i think we don't have enough of that
type of content like i do i do xbox news
and i'm kind of going to restructure my
channel the news things just od'd me
like it just has because
that look i'm usually interested in a
lot of things but it's just gotten to
the point i just don't care like i just
don't something will happen and people
like i had to make a video on this i
remember i got like five messages i
asked to make a video on
this stuff where uh about
jrpgs need more need to be on xbox and
i'm like there's like 80 videos on my
channel like you guys want me to make
another one
like i've made plenty
so
it's just like we need more like
opinionated like yeah well this well
opinionated type of content uh and i
think i'm gonna go down that direction a
little bit i'm still gonna make the news
content but it's strictly gonna be xbox
and i'm probably gonna do a lot more
live streams on my personal channel just
talking about you know stuff going on
from the day of the day but we got a uh
a super chat from christopher jones
how's the hunt for the new chair going
addicts
oh the new chair look man you your boy
is struggling man like see this chair
isn't like a hundred percent bad i don't
know if you guys could see it but i'm
used to being up a little bit more my
feet hurt right now
the the chairs kind of messed up in
general and it's just like i'm
struggling man i'm struggling so uh your
boy did find one you know what cheap so
you know definitely hit that super chat
up guys what in a cheap chair uh but you
know i'm hoping that that chair will
will bounce me back it is a mess chair
if uh i don't know if that is that how
they announce it pronounce them mesh
i don't know it's a chair that looked
comfortable and every review i looked on
it was talking about it being built more
for taller people you know people didn't
know i was sick over six foot castle
people thought i was short how
how you know you know why hey i've been
on the internet for years how do people
don't know i'm not a tall dude because
the camera is pointing down on you dude
yeah well it's not even that well not
it's not just that you do voiceover
videos b when you're with the iron lords
you're sitting down so i like cause a
lot of people don't know that i'm like
six foot three either i'm like yo i'm
not no little cat like it not
excuse me i can see it yo i didn't i
tell you who else i didn't know was like
tall uh i saw you took a picture with
maddie i didn't know someone was that
tall
yeah maddie's around my height yeah
that's this is uh enough for me
he will be coming on the show here soon
uh so yeah it was i just thought it was
interesting that people thought i was
like five foot five five foot six
no i'm not
i'm very tall uh i tower over my
girlfriend i've tried people in dinner
all my whole life i've always been the
tallest person in the room you know when
you're not the tallest person in the
room when you go to an event because
when you go to an event you come across
the other one percentage because that's
what we are we're one percenters like
i think last time i checked like the
world population only like five percent
of people was over six foot tall yeah
that is absurd so
so when i'm having the worst day of my
life and disproportionately a lot of
them are here in the us
in europe right it's just the way it
goes
but yeah
it's crazy it was it was a nice little
time man i really enjoyed it uh we got a
lot of content for you guys uh at pax
east but you know let's get on with the
show man because we got a lot to talk
about today uh keep in mind we uh k mega
will be showing up in this podcast
sooner or later uh you know he uh
because i've had a i didn't cancel on
him but last week i was going to have a
show on tuesday
but it was just so chaotic that last day
there was just no way
yeah i i was
your boy may have waited to the last
minute to do a uh
um to start packing so that that that
was uh
that was a pretty chaotic thing no look
look i will let me let me justify myself
all right because i see hustle over
there
judging me
i
i did laundry the day before the last
day so all i really realistically had to
do was just pack a bunch of stuff but
when it came down to it
i needed to
go shopping because there's some things
i needed to get i need to get like new
socks and stuff it's just like it was it
was just a crazy day left right left
right left right and i got off at 12
that day so i didn't have a whole lot of
time but you know let's get into the
show man because we got a lot to talk
about so you guys know how we do this
we give the guests
the opportunity to choose what we talk
about first so
uh shanee yeah please say i got at that
that's good enough man
correct yeah you could just do it yeah
all right so what are we talking about
first the bethesda xbox leaks the god of
war
in 2022 thing that continues to go or
the playstation forcing demos or halo
dying
playstation forcing demos
let's talk about playstation 4
all right so for those of you that know
playstation plus had a huge restructure
they put playstation now in there
initially they they maybe they're making
you play double for playstation plus
playstation now people don't want to
talk about that they want to be like oh
you know they're doing us a kind favor
no they literally just split up
playstation now into three different
tiers you had all access to all that for
ten dollars a month and that wasn't good
enough but now you have access to all
those for up to eighteen dollars a month
so
if you if you say it that way it's kind
of bad all right so one of the tiers i
believe was the 18 here wasn't it was
the ability to have access to demos yep
now we didn't know what that was we
didn't know how they were gonna handle
that but we're getting reports from like
developers and stuff that apparently
playstation is uh mandating and for
those of you that don't know what that
is uh that means they are making
people
do this they are making people
who make games i think it was over 35
dollars if you had a game that was over
35 you'd have a two hour demo and for
those of you that don't know oh that's
not a big deal that means you are making
the call of duty's have a two-hour demo
you're making um all all third party in
general second party making all those
have uh two-hour demos now that that's
not a big thing i do think that might
result into some sales
but i do know that that's going to be
more work for people in general and then
they said well we're gonna we're gonna
make playstation do it the playstation
studios acting like that that doesn't
mean they're just shifting the work
somewhere else it's like it's like they
act like because we're doing it that's
not more work so
now
let's let's get hustle in here first huh
so you you you was uh i wouldn't say you
was
for
the playstation now thing they split it
but i do think he was like in the middle
weren't you yeah yeah typically with
stuff like that uh i am i'm i'm cool
with competition in the marketplace in
terms of what playstation
now is becoming like with the tier
system i'm i'm not even cool with that
what i'm not cool with however is that
any game that cost over 40 dollars
because i read that any game that cost
over 40 dollars they're making people do
a demo
for that game
uh for those of you who may or may not
know like it pretty much takes like four
months to do a demo and i know i
mentioned this on here before but if we
were complaining about like games taking
five and six years to make already and
then you gotta add even more time on to
it
and like the fact that they're being
forced to do anything man you shouldn't
have to be forced to do nothing and demo
shouldn't be held behind the paywall no
way like that's
that's how i've always felt about that
regardless if if it was the packing and
you paid for it with the pack and it
doesn't matter
though they should be able to just like
drop whenever they want to drop um i
also read that those demos
excuse me had to be available for at
least 12 months
now i read this on 12 months yeah they
say 12 months after they drop they got
to be available for that long they said
they got got to be
at least 12 months to where you can jump
in and play or whatever the case may be
i'm not cool with that i'm not really
cool with playstation just making any
any developer do that over a game that
costs a certain amount of money
sometimes it works
but other times man it's just like you
just adding on to
the already
you know lengthy process of like making
the game in general so i mean
i'm not rolling um
i hope i don't want to say i hope it
fails i hope that
there's enough backlash to where the
developers are treated fairly if they
really want to do that they can do that
but if they don't want to do that i hope
that they treat it fair enough the way
it won't be backlash in the future with
said developers like if you're making a
new call of duty game
like well call of duty's call of duty
but if you're making anything else like
if if i decide to charge 60 for
shredders revenge shout out to the ninja
turtles and if i'm trippy games that
email and the rest of them over there
and you're gonna make me put out a demo
like nah it's no
it's almost like there's no point for me
to um
i never could co-sign that because like
that's that's just adding on to it and
then like what if you don't want to
have a demo what if you just don't want
to do that
they just won't make you do it now so i
mean now i'm not rolling man i'm not
rolling this this uh this playstation
you know service
they got they got showing proof they got
a lot to prove and and you know i hope
everybody if this service is bad because
i'll get it just because i'm on the
podcast i'll get it just to test it out
and if i don't like it y'all gonna be
the first to know just know that just
know that
all right hargy how how do you feel
about this i didn't really get uh your
opinion too much on this so it's going
to be interesting to hear your uh your
opinion in terms of playstation pretty
much saying if you want to come in our
club you need to be this this tall and
you need to have you need to have the
gold watch the spinning the spinning
necklace uh how you feel about this
it is just strange how everything sony
does this jen it just makes you scratch
your head you're like
like they were so consumer friendly last
year and you're like
what happened
all right so you're gonna charge people
to be able to play the two hours of
again that's essentially what they're
doing right as you can play the first
two hours of the game right and they're
just gonna time lock it somehow and the
store is gonna handle it but that's
exactly what you can do on steam and you
can do that on xbox you just get the
game and say oh it's not for me and
return it right we have that we've had
that option for forever right and they
just don't do that on playstation they
make you pay to get that exact feature
that we just get for free just like
cloud saves we just get that for free we
don't think about that it just happens
right but on playstation you got to pay
for it right it's just like everything
they're doing is so
it's crazy
it is weird that they still make you
play for cloud saves it is i still don't
understand that mindset
so you know anyway so this is just it's
another one of the things that they're
doing that just like makes you scratch
your head but you're you're asking
somebody to pay extra to get a game demo
that's just that's pretty nuts uh demos
should just be free and it's up to the
developer it used to be in the 360 gen
they forced that right microsoft said
hey every game has got to have a demo
right so that everybody can try it out
before they and then that kind of fell
you know fell off because developers
hated it like it takes time and so like
fine okay so it went away with the xbox
one ps4 gen and uh now i guess the store
mechanism they're just gonna kind of
give you a trial which i assume is just
the beginning of the game they're just
gonna let you play the beginning of the
game
yeah the first two hours yeah exactly uh
so it's essentially what you get with
the other platforms except you got to
pay for it right you already get that
with the other ones you just you know
return the game if you don't like it so
you know what's crazy there's a lot of
games out there that's only like six to
eight hours long yep so
you're going to let a lot of these
people play over 25 percent of the game
yeah
just
to give value to an 18 tier now i'm not
going to say that this isn't good um i
do think that this
gives that 18 tier value because people
saw the same value in ea access or yea
play now where that extra little bit of
time you're gonna play game really
resonates and it gives you the
opportunity to decide if you want that
game or not but
play ea access and play
in ea play we're only charging five
dollars a month
this is 18 a month that they're charging
you just to occasionally play because i
don't think it's going to be every game
i do feel like there's going to be
studios that's going to be like
what what
you want us to let someone put in i
don't even think it's a standpoint of
making something longer because if it's
only the two hour game you know you just
make that two hours um you know playable
on a different kind of format and you
let that happen i think what's going to
be the issue is i think that
it's going to be like i said people are
going to be a huge fan
of letting people play
that much portion of their game
and it could be for a variety of
different reasons one because some of
these games
you know they're not that long so you're
gonna let them play a good amount of the
game even with that two hours two
some of these games aren't that good
so you're giving them the option not to
fully commit i don't think a lot of
people are going to really
put that in there so go ahead and uh
take over because i gotta figure out
what's wrong with my mic now yeah yeah
okay i thought i was the only one
oh you're a little choppy i got you so
we got a two dollar super chat from
jonas the dad um
how do you do a two hour trial of an
open world rpg let me attempt to answer
your question
i'm assuming you got up yeah for forever
because because i'm assuming you got to
build how does that sound the whole game
much better better yeah much better i'm
assuming don't you gotta like build the
whole game and you just like i don't
know man i don't know not unless like i
feel i feel like maybe you don't
give out the whole game i figured if
it's an rpg and if it's an open world
rpg you can do it like a persona style
you don't make the world open what you
do is you just make like the first
half of palace of dungeon or kingdom or
whatever you make that open you play hey
if you like this here's our system and
it's like you just got to kind of do a
hard stop on that so i mean i if it was
me i'm definitely giving up the whole
whole everything man and
yes sorry i'll add to the ea access
thing there's one other there's a couple
of points first it's not two hours right
it's like 10. and then second
you actually uh you know will get that
game in ea access eventually right after
six months eight months ten months
they're gonna put that game in the
access so it's not just that yeah you
get to try the game out but after a
while it's gonna be in your service
that's not guaranteed with any of these
right that's just uh hey you get a trial
of supposedly all games that are in the
store i think that are over 50 right so
it's 34 to the publisher but uh 50 to
the consumer that have to have this
feature
i met and what's funny is i assume that
that's going to carry over the full game
whatever kind of content you do in that
two hours
but it's like
imagine
doing this with something like ea where
people are already
like extremely
skeptical of like newer maddens
newer 2k games over there at 2k 2k uh
you know um w uh what is that 2k the
basketball game
nba
nba 2k
madden
fifa where people are already skeptical
and they're like well let me just try
this two hour demo which obviously
they have their own thing but i'm
curious to see if subscription services
are going to carry over like are they
going to be able to convince playstation
that's already offering the service uh
to convince ea to do it
i'm doubtful and they make a lot of
games
so apparently they're going to have to
though right and that's the point yeah
but it's like
you play some of these games you play
nba 2k
and then you realize it's not the same
they don't buy it you play you know
a game that's broken we have a lot of
broken games these days you realize
this isn't it and they don't buy it like
i i
and i actually i'm for this in a way
because i do feel like there's not is
there's not a whole lot of protection
towards us to consumers it's like i feel
like you know on xbox you're fine steam
you're fine nintendo you might as well
just
just throw money into a well uh
playstation mods just throw money into
the well because they're not going to
give you that money back
it doesn't matter if the game doesn't
work returner literally wasn't working
and i know people that were not getting
returns yeah and to me
there needs to be more protection for
the consumers when you're buying these
broken games and i don't think there is
so you know hopefully this if there's
anything that comes out of this it's
that
sony
gives some kind of consumer friendly
thing to the consumers to not buy these
games that are broken but one thing i
will say
is if this
takes off and it's very successful
i i'm waiting for that game pass
ultimate same requirements
because they're like oh you're already
doing it with with playstation uh plus
or whatever they call playstation plus
premium or essential it's like
since you're already doing it just do it
for our game pass ultimate
okay because that's competition i think
if microsoft ever does anything like
that they'd just give it to us for free
they wouldn't put it under a game pass
they'd just give it to you for free i
don't know i feel like they they would
but then a part of me feels like if
someone else is doing it and they're
getting a bag
and they're not getting backlash
microsoft's going to go right behind
them with the halloween bag getting the
fans strong i'm thinking of phil and
phil's going to be like
nah i don't want to charge you for that
i wouldn't want to pay for that
i i could see them doing a marketing
thing that's like we don't charge for
yeah that used to have access to already
yeah it it it will be it'll be
interesting that'll be interesting i'm
just when it comes to something like
this
i'm curious to see where it goes but i
don't like the way it's doing
uh and i'm curious to see exactly how
playstation handles a note
like if if if if i'm making a game and
it's hot let's say the next red dead
and
it would be beneficial for them to have
that two hours
and xbox doesn't
but
if you walked up to 2k well rockstar and
you were like we want this we want these
two hours and rockstar is like no
is there going to be repercussions
because if you don't
it because to me the only way this works
is you have a blanket blank statement
where everyone has to do it no one can
say no or you are out of here
and then i feel like that's going to
open up holes because some developers
are going to say no and you're going to
have this situation to where
you're going to to cherry pick yeah oh
rockstar's new game we need that you can
well you that's fine you can back out we
won't punish you
but then like a new game from like
ubisoft you're off the store
so like i feel like it's never going to
realistically happen for everyone and
that that's just me
what up came back what up yeah what's
happening hey
all right so so what's up
k meg is a little late he was he was
driving home
all right so where we are right now in
this you know what i like about uh
stream yard because i don't really use
it too much it notified me they're like
yo okay meg is here he's in there click
that button and i was like okay okay
i'll let him in now all right so what
we're talking about now is the
playstation forcing demos you know where
the uh you know it's rumored let's let's
be real here it's not official but i
think we can all agree that this sounds
just like playstation so
they walking in there they they the demo
police everybody hides your games
because they're gonna make you sample
some of them uh so how do you feel about
that okay megan do you feel like
playstation should be doing something
like that
uh i don't know i
just leave that today fan base
personally i mean me myself
um i don't like it i think that
um to to have games be placed in a
position
uh
to a high tier
is
a little fraudulent to me i don't like
it i mean you know what i'm saying i
mean demos should be something that
should be free for everybody um it's
good for promotion things like that but
if you just but uh you know i've seen
people trying to talk about that this
was value
not the same uh because if you try to
talk about value when you look at what
the competition is doing it's not
nowhere near the same because the
competition is giving you games that you
can play the full
the full fledge of games out there
available through game pass um and this
right here is just demos i mean hell ea
even lets you get 10 hours
so two hours uh for certain type of
titles it's cool but
personally i i i
still think that it just should be
should be free not behind a paywall and
we were saying earlier uh came back i
don't know if you agree can you guys
hear me phone
we were saying earlier that some games
two hours is damn near to a quarter of
the game if not more
yeah so so it's just like
are these games gonna do it and like i
was saying too
you know some studios don't want you
playing two hours of their game before
right
right and especially if playstation is
uh if that rumor is true that they're
going to be the ones uh to take over the
range to do the demo so obviously
they're going to try to find the fullest
best most entertaining parts of the game
to get people to buy in
and so
like you said the developers could be
like yo this was a really pivotal part
of this game that we wanted to fans to
that buys the game to go ahead and
experience not to go in here and to
throw it out here in the demo and get
people hyped and then next thing you
know
uh people over here
dog piling on the game because the game
just didn't live up to the expectations
through that two hours so
it's a catch-22 like i said i'm for
anybody that's that's supporting it
that's cool
but for me personally
i just i'm not feeling it i think that
it just should be playstation should be
doing something else
um in regards instead of just trying to
do a two-hour demo elective
shout out to hip-hop game here uh yo
what's up
[Music]
what's up son and much love to everyone
on the show god bless and keep grinding
son uh join us we we're gonna have to
get you on here in a couple of weeks so
yeah i'm gonna eventually have king back
on because uh people love king uh his
foolishness uh so it's see i'm not like
called to all of him run wild
so
uh you know i might i might get you on
the same show because i feel like i feel
like somebody between you might be uh
might be enjoyable man i'm doing this
for my entertainment just as much as you
guys
so you know that's all you can really
talk about when it comes to you know the
playstation forcing demos people in the
chat or making fun of the demo police
statement i said look
i do feel like they're gonna be saying
that man when it's like
am i
i'm still bugging again like i don't
understand you're back to normal let's
get back to normal now yeah
oh my gosh man i probably i don't know
maybe it's my internet maybe they're
working on a poll or something around
here i don't know all right so let's
let's let's get to
halo dying
for those you know we got a season two
of halo infinite we got a god awful tv
show called halo
see
that that's perfectly fine because uh
have you ever seen those those those cut
scenes in those old uh dynasty warriors
where it's one person fighting a
thousand
yeah i'm not one person okay i don't
care i got a spear and i got no problem
using it
i will say my stuff if i want to so you
know obviously we got all this you got
you know a season two that people were
anticipating uh they regardless what
their anticipations was and what they
thought was gonna happen they have a lot
of things going on and of what they
expected from halo as a brand right now
and i will say that
i do feel like there are certain things
that we need to address uh certainly the
the conflict from uh the halo infinite
season two i want to go to heart knee uh
first because uh you know i i've talked
to k mega and hustle about a thousand
times by halo uh i could i can already
shoot them down with a sniper rifle do
you know what they're gonna say but i
don't know what heart needs gonna say so
uh you know i gotta know if he's going
to be the one so how do you feel about
where the state of halo in general game
tv show just media in general
so
like gas i think they should have
delayed us
so uh you know the co-op thing bugged
the hell out of me i i've never played
halo without co-op it's never released
without co-op that could be any freaking
halo it's always had co-op and they
released this one without call i think
that was just just ridiculous now i get
it people needed to play the you know
they need to get the game out and people
were able to play solo and they were
able to play multiplayer and then you
know competitive space whatever but
um
look they're obviously having issues
right that's just the way it is they're
having issues uh they i don't know if
it's management or not
or or maybe the structure of how they
did the work where they had contractors
doing some of it they're having an issue
transitioning to actually get some of
the work done to create new content um
and then finalize co-op and
you know the forge capability to
actually make you know user content
um
it is disappointing i can't pile on them
because i don't know where they are
right i'm not in there to see is it like
is it bonnie's fault is it somebody else
in the you know in within 343 is
something else just structurally wrong
that we're just not aware of
i don't know right so it's hard to say
it's this but you you tend to look at
the way things are going and you say
well shouldn't management have done this
to
make that better or do that to make that
better and make it so that they can get
things done so something is going on
there um i think they're in okay shape
as long as they can start delivering
content faster they've decided the next
couple of seasons is gonna be six months
that can be a little long
uh if they can get their you know
cadence going and get back to like a two
to three month release window that'll be
better
uh the two maps
it's still just way too little um i
think they need to be releasing at least
i think they need to be taking some of
those old maps halo one two three
there's like classic awesome maps bring
them right i i don't know what it takes
to get like it it shouldn't take an
eternity to bring some of those classic
maps over uh especially those big teams
there's like three maps for big tv you
just get so sick of the same ones over
and over so i'd love to bring some of
those bigger maps in um the tv show i've
not watched and have no interest in so
wait a minute but that that slow slow
down on the last part hey um hockey i do
want to like uh you know capitalize on
oh you know just coming off what you're
saying right
bro all i got to do is add forge and let
the fan base put some maps back in there
that's it
you know we're gonna have people that's
gonna do that in that community um
the season lasts in six months hey bro
that's crazy season's supposed to last
three months yeah if we we're really
talking like that three months out of
the year you do what you do yeah it is
what it is
um it's only two new maps and i know
it's a king of the hill is a game mode
that they're adding in if it's not there
already i know i'm excited for that
personally but dog look it's not enough
man the last uh let's play account that
i got from steam was like six thousand
people i i want to put this in
perspective for y'all
xbox let that mario die off and what i'm
saying is halo master chief you know the
people that you know the one that
he's the top dog he's supposed to be
like number one he's supposed to been
their most precious ip that put xbox on
the map and it did
i want y'all to just be aware that
guess five
guest five has lasted way longer than
halo infinite now who would have thought
that outside of me let's see see erica
merc outside of the troubleshoot who
would have thought who would have
thought this thing well i mean
you could last longer when you came out
like three years ago too oh
you could easily have content out to
attribute to something no man came out
like a decade ago it feels like and they
fix that game yeah i can i can co-sign
with with uh a little bit with with uh
what hustle said but not all of it for
this reason because for one okay now yes
it six months is way too long um it's it
only seems like the content is going to
be bite-sized for having the gamers wait
for that long for that game to to come
out i mean especially when you're doing
a free to play that you could just tell
that 343 was not prepared for that type
of energy with come with with changing
halo from this from what it was to
this model so
um that is where the criticism
definitely lies i mean everybody knows
who follows me or even seen anything say
i am a big 343 supporter um
but yeah no the criticism is is
definitely warranted
this being said though co-op will be
coming in august
so
that's a good thing um
the map situation i am totally in
agreeance um that yeah if you could you
know you're only giving us what two to
three maps
that is not enough you could have easily
brought uh
something with blood gulch any of the
old classic wow
yeah yeah all of them i mean they could
they could to substitute in order until
they were going to get their maps uh
available for for the gamers now again
forge is on a whole nother level um
forge on halo 5 was really really good
damn good but this forge that they're
doing is on a absolutely massive scale
this thing that's why it's going to take
that's why we weren't going to find
anything about it until most likely 2023
uh i they they say
you might find something out about it in
the year i say it's going to be sometime
uh
probably you know around this time next
year um
the other the thing that i've thought i
said that i am pushing back on though is
the game is not dead just because you
get steam numbers
that
that's yeah you know what i'm saying
other people but see this is one thing
too yeah steam doesn't really equate for
all of it because it's still top 10
in on xbox and on top of that
it is uh on top of that people are that
that's not playing halo infinite because
they're in a position right now to you
know like they're bored with just what
the content is right now they're going
to master chief collection so they're
still looking for halo they're still
enjoying themselves playing some type of
halo
wait wait wait wait wait yeah yeah hey
megan shout out to you because you
actually brought up a stat that i forgot
to bring up there are more players on
the master chief collection right now
than the new hotness which is halo
infinite right
well this
because no more maps more content
everything so that's what's happening
all of it yeah it's really not fair
comparing the master chief collection to
halo infinite because it's not even just
you know the maps
plastics in a way you can because this
is the reason remember when everybody
i've had me and my boy xbox 448 they
were we were an argument they were
saying the uh master chief collection is
dead i said no for something that
ambitious they're not going to give up
on it they're going to bring it back
it's just going to take a while because
they just missed the mark this is the
same type of ordeal just not as
catastrophic as what it was for a master
chief collection
so because everybody will tell you when
they play even the haters of halo when
they played their game
they they say it played halo infinite
they're like oh man this game feels good
it plays good but it's just whatever
whatever whatever whatever everybody got
their own tape but the main reason is
because of the content
the one thing i will agree with as well
and i said this to my boy don
and um is that halos should have they
should 343 should have bid it
uh xbox should have bit bit the bullet
for a little while and just delayed the
game until season two dropped at that
point you could have still kept feeding
the fan base all these other little um
what they've been doing beforehand like
they started off in the summer and then
like showing new maps getting people
acquainted you know then they could be
doing all this other stuff because what
really hurt them was that whole
situation to tobacco that happened
during the um at the end of the year
where people went home because they were
trying to enjoy the holidays and then
things went left so
uh if you delayed it then you might
could have got some more maps maybe
different ideas to say well what can we
put to substitute right now in order to
get the fan base excited for when we
dropped the game in march instead of
when we said we were going to do it in
december because december is a weird
month anyway to be dropping a new ip
especially a game that size or you know
i'm saying especially a franchise like
that so
um just delay it
eat some crow and then just drop the
game and i think we could have all been
it could have been better suited and
everybody would have been happy right
now and excited for the game to drop
instead of right now i'm talking about
where's the beef you see what i'm saying
so that that's the whole thing yeah
before anybody else goes for the record
i do like halo infinite i love the
multiplayer i played much played the
hell of the monster i had like 40 hours
in it it's not that the game isn't fun
it's just super limited it's not a bad
game whatsoever and i'm you know cutting
jokes whatever but that's just because
i'm just messing around but
it's sad to even see that 343 has even
been put in this position like i put in
um i'm putting the chat i said free 343.
i don't really think that they can
handle what's going on and it's obvious
because they they brought back jason
stanton from out of i don't say
retirement but they brought him back
from wherever he was and then they got
another like studio working with him hey
look
free bonnie ross at that point because i
don't know if they even want to work on
it at this point because this is
i mean look for lack of a better term
this has been abysmal like the whole
thing like regardless of what's
whatever's been going on
like
heart gate you have brought it up early
like yeah the co-op not being there they
won yo that's like a staple in halo like
that was there since day one from halo
one yeah me and my brother ran through
them joints they had fun it's just one
of them things yeah and for not to be
there yeah that's that's a blow um
i said it earlier yo you could have put
forge in that joint and you know people
would have went home oh yeah the
community was just like now we got it
yeah we got it y'all gotta put us on
payroll yeah
y'all can just wait yeah y'all could
just wait let me let me make this other
point too is that and i'm and i'm
feeling with you on that one hustle
because
i've been an advocate for this forever
you know i'm like
it's gonna be even if
and they tried they tried as hard as
they can even if you played the story
you beat the game
they tried to go back to the ties and
and to the root of hey bungie's halo
right you still you got that feeling of
it when you play the multiplayer you got
that feeling that vibe i said the best
way that they were going to try to do
this is try to combine what the old halo
fan enjoy in what the fans of halo 4
through 5 enjoys right so which i'm a
huge fan of halo 4 and 5. so
um and they did that but it still wasn't
enough and then on top of that when they
still cater to that same old halo fan
what did they do
how many how many how many people was on
steam
how many people were playing on same six
thousand they bailed out on it they
bailed out and went right back to the
old halos one through four or one
through three pretty much so again
if you if anything that you could say
about
uh the whole god of war situation with
santa monica when they did they did it
their way
i was one of those people that were like
man what come on man what are they
talking about cradles are dad what the
what do you nah bruh i ain't feeling it
then i got a chance to play the game and
then i'm like okay i see boy balrog
you're a genius you guys out there in
santa monica y'all geniuses for this i
feel this game i feel it i like it i
still prefer the older you know raw
anti-hero kratos but i can dig this
cradle so i can understand this whole
situation right
this is why
when you say free uh 343 or free bonnie
but let them have their true creative
freedom everybody was over here talk
about let xbox have you know people
creative freedom for the devs
the gamers the old school halo gamers
didn't want them to have creative
freedom in order to make the halo that i
think would have probably been
astronomically better
but the fact of it is is that they
wanted to cater to a group of people
that was will never agree or never
associate will never uh want 343 to
succeed because they only want bungie to
be working on halo so that's why i hope
that when they start doing this new
content start doing all this stuff they
paid the homage now go ahead and do your
have your creative freedom and do what
you need to do that's that's always been
my opinion i still stand by that
all right let me get this super chat
real quick you know what i like about uh
straight yards too like you can actually
put the super chat in the uh the the
podcast so we got a two dollar super
chat from john tj
stop hating on the halo tv show
man preach he preaching right there
if you feel like i've been hating on
this tv show you might want to leave
oh before god come on bro the show is
great you didn't like the last the last
episode oh we we we go get it we go okay
okay
come on
sorry guys
i'm gonna go ahead and say what you
think yeah so it's just like one thing
that came out you you pointed out that
made me kind of think about this there's
also no road map and that was kind of a
pain right right they released the game
we have no idea is this going to be like
more campaign content coming
is this a 10-year game and then the next
chapter comes after 10 years right like
they just gave us a part of that ring
and then just left it at that right are
we gonna see the rest of that ring oh
you know like are we gonna do the other
bosses right there's like four or five
of these people that are under you know
they are going to do i know for a fact
that they're going to be doing other
parts of the ring and they are going to
add more content and bring in more um
stories outside of chief
which yeah exactly and that's that's
what they need to do because halo is not
all about master chief there will be
people that are arguing me down about it
exactly
but the universe is what's important and
that's why i
take a shot at my boy attic love the
halo tv show it's because i wish halo
was more like mass effect
than what
then going to the same going to rings
all the damn time seeing you know you
know fighting the same [ __ ]
that's why i i want their vision to come
out because halo 5 was a was giving me
that vision and i loved it even though
the story was not complete if there was
there were some hiccups there but i
loved the whole fact of how they merged
the team osiris and blue team and then
you know and and and took us to sileos
and all that other [ __ ] i loved it i
love it i loved it i loved it so you
know i'm done on that aspect
yeah that would be awesome right so yeah
they finally go to like like high
busters totally different but oh my god
real gears right and like they could do
all sorts of cool things like that right
even give us backstory and like like
there could be all sorts of cool things
they could pull off right
but yeah if they'd just been open about
that when they released the game hey
this isn't the end we got all this stuff
coming don't worry all right we got you
yeah
here
here's my issue
my issue with this matter is
i do understand where you guys are
coming from in a lot of scenarios
um but i do feel like oh there there's a
you guys are you guys are ridiculous
with this this tv show we got a two
dollar super chat from carlos halo tv
show is fire can't wait for episode six
all right we'll get some carlos let's go
and tj we'll get to you guys here in a
second um i'm not worried too much about
halo and the reason i'm not worried
about halo is right uh
i do know a little bit more on what
what's going on in the public i can't
really go into it because
it's very clear
that i know stuff i should know but what
i will say is
things
the reason things are weighted is now is
is a combination of variables that
happen in the past
things have been cleared up now but it's
going to take time to catch up to that
now
if a gang like no man's sky
can rejuvenate itself
if a game like
what's another game
um
what's that other game that was called
that came out it did really bad at first
fortnite
fortnite well not even fortnight oh man
but you guys get what i'm saying games
like
pubg pub g is another one that kind of
started went down and then came back yep
if these type of games can come back
rainbow six siege
and it came back now i'm not saying they
don't have a a long thing a long road
ahead i do feel like they do
but what i will say
is they need more things now i don't
know if you guys saw the reddit uh
leak did you guys see that
no no i don't think so all right uh so
i'll find that here in one second but so
pretty much
they need stuff to justify these
six-month waiting periods now six months
for a game for a season
is crazy
six months is like what destiny had when
it got delayed and was waiting all that
time for the new expansion it was the
longest time of my life and i wouldn't
mind a six month
if it made sense content was coming out
if everyone was doing what they were
supposed to i wouldn't mind a six-month
waiting period but it doesn't feel like
it's six months because it's gotta be
six months it feels like it's six months
because the game is so far behind in
in the development cycle and i think
that's the biggest thing we have here
now is that halo is constantly doing
nothing but trying to catch up
and when you're doing nothing but trying
to catch up you can't get ahead of
anything so what you see they're posting
now is probably what they posted
is probably what they started working on
months ago uh and that that's the
biggest thing that i think that we have
issues with right now is we're not ever
it's going to be a while before we see
this stuff like really come in tuition
because we're constantly seeing stuff
that was made years ago uh because
they're finally catching up to it i
can't really find the uh the one but
it's pretty much saying that there was
that
they were in rumor to be making a hero
mode like a hero shooter mode and hey
the br right yeah and
okay look i know a lot of people don't
like the kind of concept of that because
it's halo they want that arena based
thing uh but i do think modes like that
in the six month thing is go it would
help them yeah you know and i think one
of the issues that i personally feel
like is going on is they're constant
they spent too much time at the
beginning a
making
the um
the space slip engine
i think
yeah slip space they're still trying to
figure out how to utilize that engine to
the best of their ability and i don't
feel like they had a very good
uh concept on coming down and saying
this is it instead of constantly
restructuring for instance i was in a
discord with gaming forte and slo-mo
they were making uh a new intro you
probably see that sometime today so
definitely go follow them on twitter uh
they're probably gonna get mad if i
spoiled that but my bad so
um
they were constantly bickering back and
forth each other on you know
what was in there what's not in there
what is that doing that's delaying
progress
and when you're constantly doing that
and you do that on a bigger scale way
bigger scale where you don't you can't
grab onto something that you want on you
know what i'm saying you can't oh let's
do this they spent three or four months
trying to do that idea okay we don't
want to do that and when you're having
this happen consistently all the time it
seems like that has
drastically delayed the progress scale
in this game and so you know if they
would have stuck to something like this
they would have had this hero thing to
put in the game right now that you know
sure some might not have liked it but
don't make it a consistent mode what you
want to do is you want to make it to
where
it's a timed theme uh you know for
instance in destiny that play you know
we have a lot of timed events you know
you don't have to have the base gameplay
if it's a timed event
it would just be interesting you know we
got a
five dollar super draft from artemis
uh and today's erotic whatever you know
how i came about look dude
at this point i think we've established
if you super chat i'm gonna mispronounce
your name and i think some of you love
this let's let that man be country
that's all right i love it
today's halo event they said they're
going to do monthly content drops thank
you
this is part of the example i was
talking about where
i don't mind the six months if the sixth
month is actually fun
and it's engaging
but if it's like it was the last delay
keep that up in the don't don't drop
that so then we got
a five dollar subtract from uh on tv
fire bonnie raw she had six years to
have this game ready i'm tired of her
excuses
yeah pump the brakes she saved halo
because they were going to sell that to
gearbox they were going to sell the
franchise to gearbox and she
saved halo give yeah pump the brakes
pump the brakes
so
now
like are you done with that statement
jack i don't want to overtalk you okay
mega oh no no no no no okay
so i i don't agree with that um i do
think bonnie ross is more of a
figurehead at this point i don't think
she has a whole lot of say in terms of
what the development of the cycle things
i think you see here more how the the
halo brand is represented outside of the
game at this point
not necessarily how the game is being
made in halo infinite i think that's
more of statin more than anyone but you
know back to my original thing i do feel
like one of the key things that they're
going to have to do on this is they're
going to have to hit
very loudly a battle royale that's going
to appeal to the people in fortnight to
the people and in apex legends i i want
to point out that i don't think
they need it but i do think it would
help draw these people in of the people
that they have been trying to get
because at the end of the day when these
people play
arena for a day or two
then they leave where are they going uh
hardy where are they going
usually the other battle royale yeah
right when you don't have a battle
royale to compete with the other battle
royales you're gonna have an issue and
what what's crazy is you competed in
price point battle royale advocate huh
yeah you competed with price point
because that's where the other battle
royales are but you didn't compete with
the thing they actually have
for them is that battle royale
mode like i said
today's game does not need battle royale
to live
but i am going to tell you
this game needs battle royale to compete
those are two different things uh
the battle royale is the difference
between you being the number one thing
played on twitch number one they played
on xbox and 360 and then and the number
eight being played on stuff it's just
gonna succeed but not as well we got a
10 super trap from drawing tj let's see
what he's got to say this time
it's still a massive issue joseph is a
better fit i agree with you now i i
don't necessarily know exactly what's
going on there uh but i do have a lot of
faith and stuff now
now we're going to talk about the tv
show all right
for those of you in the chat the same
addict
why wha what about episode five
what about episode five
uh sure they had some action things oh
and if if all of you was was content
with that action scene then you know i
don't know go play call of duty because
that's clearly all you want to do
just because you have people getting
shot made it a good episode doesn't
completely fix the past five four
episodes that come before it
master chief is not master chief in the
show
that's all i have to say
you can have all the the the elite
killing you can have all the the grunts
stomping for some reason people at
energy stores that should not have
energy shores we won't go too much into
that
i get it
people are saying
attic this isn't
the
t this isn't the video game never
expected the video but you know what i
did expect paramount to respect the
video game
that's what i did expect okay and i'm
gonna be real with you
they they're just not respecting it but
you know we're not gonna get into this
because i all it takes is one of you
three to trigger me and we won't go on
to another topic so we're not gonna talk
about this much more but you guys wanted
my opinion on episode five you got it it
was a good episode but it doesn't make
the season a great show so let's let's
move on to the next
topic
uh and i think you guys are going to
enjoy this topic because i i i i enjoyed
it so god of war
2022 are people still coming out on top
of every mountain known to man saying
god of war is coming out in 2022. oh i
don't know i want to go around the table
and i want to get people's temperature
on where this game's coming up first
person we're going to start with is k
mega
k mega
is god of war coming out in 2022 let me
go and get the super chat before you
answer
yes
drawn tj oh my god
okay first off draw tj
find out super chat addict this isn't
canon exactly what i just said to the
halo game franchise breathe my friend
breathe
listen
to tj yeah
uh
i say no i say it i i just
we haven't seen anything yet if we don't
see anything here by
i say by the end of may
uh i just don't see it i just don't see
it coming out this year because if i'm
okay because let's look at this whole
situation when is the last game that
sony brought out
that
at the end of the year when uh at the
end of the year and it did well
because the only game that i could think
of that's that sony brought out uh at
the end of the year
that
did well
was spider-man that was it but that came
out in what september
september 2018 yeah september
anything any if you don't put if you
don't put god of war in september i
don't see it coming because of that
reason it's it's gonna
it's one of those things like okay they
have a deal they have they still have
the uh marketing rights for call of duty
there's other games that i'm pretty sure
sony's going to have marketing rights
too and then on top of that all of the
big games are going to be coming out
there you got forsake for spoken and
you're going to have the uh uh uh paul's
works game worse how do you say that
hogwarts yes thank you sir um a game
coming out and then you're going to have
just other big titles that's going to be
coming out on top of that star field
you put god of war in there yeah god of
war is still going to sell but it's not
going to sell like it would like when
they normally put their games out in the
beginning of the year during tax time
that's that was the smartest decision
sony ever did was put their games in the
first quarter of the year
they bring out god of war there it will
sell but it will not sell to the degree
of what it would if they put it out in
2023 so that is my reasoning behind it
if they don't put it out uh they have to
put it in september
october afterwards uh it just it's going
to get aid alive and i i just
and and i know that some people disagree
with me but i wow what
real quick yeah we're going to go yes
because yeah first last time
god of war i know i know you love that
game yeah and i know you played 24 7. i
know you dream of of cradles and atrial
fibrillation
so
what i well my question to you hargy is
do you think 100 in your bones that this
game's coming out in the year of 2022.
uh 100 hell no i would never say 100 uh
i'd give it a good 60 chance it will
come out this year
but for all the things you said that's
the problem
right they don't want it's not going to
come out after october it's just not
going to happen because they want to
release the game this year and be in the
in the game of the year discussion so
they're not going to come up after
october
now as you get closer to the fall you do
have to contend with all the other games
that come out right it is what it is
right so
i if they if they come out august
september okay that's probably realistic
but that's pretty damn close
i don't know uh if it's still possible
i'll still say it's possible i'll give
it a 60 chance it comes out this year
i'll say 40 chance it gets too late
until next year and i think as it gets
closer to that time if they're not ready
even if it could come out in like
november 10th
one day before starfield they're
definitely not coming up this year it'll
get delayed
so
okay
so
hustle yeah i know i know
out of all of us you're definitely the
the more of the playstation centric
person than people such as myself or
okay mega just tell me giddy up eddie
just tell me giddy up it's okay i don't
i don't i don't call people names okay
that's not in my in my character but i
will say that you typically
lean more blue i do uh but you know so
so how do you feel do you still feel in
your bones
that that x that playstation still going
to deliver that that greatness god of
war
ragnarok the year of 2022.
well i've said this before and then
okay meg i'm going to get at you in a
minute don't worry
right there oh i'm right i said this
before man if we don't see nothing by
the playstation equivalent of e3 this
year then it's probably getting pushed
out the way um
came back earlier you had said that um
you know
pretty much it shouldn't release in
october or november because you said
there's competition there right i know
what type of competition there because i
know you're not talking about style
field because we don't really know what
that's about just yet so i don't know
about star field so i agree
we gotta slow that down we gotta slow
that down a little bit all right yo
y'all understand understand this yo
god of war 2018
all the accolades you got game of the
year they stand in the third it took
over the killing awards and look put
their foot up everybody ass so we can't
sit up here and act like we're not gonna
be back it's like it's gonna be drake
it's going back to back though
we can't we can't just let the y'all
can't keep bleeding green all over
the place
yes
i just want to point out that we could
do whatever we want oh man all right
well listen listen let me let me let me
tell y'all something
if this game is anything like the first
one i only got three and a half hours in
it
i ain't worried about nothing but again
if we don't see it by like in all
seriousness i'm just messing around with
y'all but i want to see about joe man
june or july at the latest
yeah it's not gonna it's not gonna
drop this [ __ ] but i do want to say this
though um came mega earlier you said
with playstation games released in you
know in the later part of the year
and
what games were successful um demon
souls when the ps5 dropped and what's
the other one uh
spider-man morales was the other one
y'all give me one second i'll be right
back okay but with that that was launch
yeah are launch titles those were launch
titles so
you know you got that but then you know
there's a there's a there's a you know
you got to split that in half a little
bit because when you look at like when
they tried to bring uh death stranding
you got it alive
i mean ea did it to themselves when they
tried to come out with titanfall 2 and
uh battlefield and then there was uh
that i think it was battlefield 1 and
then there was call of duty there look
call of duty is the is going to dominate
every time that it drops and then this
is going to be a highly anticipated uh
uh call of duty at that so
i don't care i don't care what and then
again
that's what i'm saying sony has the
marketing rights to call of duty so why
would you put call of duty out and we'll
got a war out a round and run the same
time of uh of of uh uh uh battle god of
war instead
okay let me calm down
why would you put god of war
in the in that same time frame as uh
call of duty when you have the marketing
rights because that right there you want
as many pre-orders as possible you're
going to pause problems between those
pre-orders and sales if you put them
anywhere near each other on top of the
other games that other gamers are going
to want and that want to get as well god
of war will sell like i said it it is a
behemoth that will sell but it won't
sell as well as it would if it was at
the beginning of the year that's my only
thought so i'm i'm with i'm i'm with uh
with with uh with homeboy down here
because i can't i was gonna try to say
your name but i'm not gonna do it um
hockey
okay all right so i'm just yeah our geek
i was going to try to say the last name
but no i won't do that
i will disrespect you like that so but
no that's the whole thing but that's why
i agree with him 60
uh you know 40.
but it's going to have to be in
september
or early october because they're still
gonna look
i know that this is going to sound funny
to you but
i feel that for to harad i mean forza uh
motorsport's going to drop too and then
you have you got that game coming out
even though i know that that's that's a
that's an xbox game or whatever but the
whole point of that that's going to get
buzzed we the same game like horizon uh
horizon zero dawn got all those
accolades
and look what happened when just one big
title comes out what if we don't even
know if nintendo's going to drop a bomb
this year or not either
so and eldon ring just just took all the
win out of uh out of forbidden west sale
so
the same thing could happen especially
let's just say that uh for spoken is a
really good game
and or or the uh the uh the hog warts
game if that's a really good game those
games if you get word of mouth that
those games are really good people will
go and try to get to those games as well
and that's going to hurt the sales
overall that's why i'm still thinking
that it's going to be early uh in the
year but if i'm wrong then i'll i'll uh
i'll i'll say i'm wrong there no big
deal about it
all right can you guys hear me yeah
here's where i stand with this
originally you can ask hustle
let me get some of these super chats
before i forget it you guys are still
talking about the tv show
trying to trigger me i get you but you
ain't gonna ha it ain't gonna work today
it's not going to we're going to go
along with the tv show real quick yeah
finally subscribe from victor alex team
probably butcher it's fine you talk
about the tv show when i told you to
stop anyway i think the tv show should
have focused on locking the fire team
osiris and had a chief cameo that way
that the helmet thing would have not
been would have been fine i actually
agree with you i actually
said i would have loved that at that
time i don't think locke was a spartan
so i feel like
um sergeant johnson should have had his
own tv show he should have been the
prime uh center and it should have
explained him going up the ranks i don't
know logistically how many people would
have watched that because when you see
halo you see spartans if he's not a
spartan might have been an issue so i
don't know how that would have gone but
i i definitely understand i i said that
on iop not too long ago
then we got to find out the super trout
from um
dickato
i don't know man
won't you correct me on that uh hustle
cracks
i don't think i can um
good so it's not just we got one we got
one boys we got one let's see
see it would be man they will not delay
god of war if it is ready xbox is
collectively gaining large share market
that has seven years to create a
dangerous president i agree with you on
that one i think we got one more then we
gotta fight our superchat from drawn tj
sonya is screwed after 2023 beyond
banger after breaker and game pass you
know what uh drawing tj i need to import
the emotes from the uh from iop because
i would put you on something if i had it
but i don't have it so it is
what it is all right so here's where i
stand with this
you can ask household originally i was a
hundred percent actually he's this way
no he's this way how's that
all right originally i was 100
god awards next year
now i'm like 70 30.
um because usually
my sony never releases on the holidays
but part of me feels like they're going
to break it this year
i don't know why because one thing
you don't constantly have people on
twitter out there
they outside they constantly saying it's
coming out this year you might have one
person say something like that but to
have everyone constantly reassuring
people what's coming out this year it's
weird to me
it's definitely way energy making me
feel like
they might catch me outside if i keep
saying it's not coming out this year
like so so then being that
admin that is coming out this year is
making me back up saying it's not coming
out this year
but ed you can't really say that because
corey ballock had just came out i think
that we were sorted to the podcast but
you went to pax like i think it was that
monday or whatever day that was it came
out was like yo we we working on it and
when we got something dope to show you
when we feel like it's ready we're going
to show it to you so i don't know man it
might drop next year i hope it don't
like i said hopefully we'll see
something in jonah and i feel like
they're putting
whatever pressure they're putting on um
so now saying that let me not say press
let me rephrase that i feel like they're
working harder to be able to deliver
something around e3 of this year even
regardless of what corey said i know he
came out and said we you know they
taking their time and everything that's
probably because they don't want jason
trying on his ass we're just going to be
real well they don't want the bloomberg
articles he don't want crunch you don't
want this that in the third but i think
they i think they're going to have
something i think they're cooking
something up right now and i definitely
gonna have something around june this
year
here's what i think about that hustle to
me
i understand first off i put a a poll in
the chat you guys could definitely go
and participate that um you know i was
going to put a third one say addicts
right but it would completely defeat the
pole so i didn't do it all right so to
me when you're looking at something like
this i do feel like i understand where
you're coming from hustle
but
it would be different if one person
stepped outside and said it but there's
been like three people to step outside
and say it
and that makes me feel like
they're about to announce
a state of play probably the next month
where it's going to show a sizable
amount of gameplay for god of war and
then this game's coming out probably in
september october november i know that's
three months that's a long time to be
seeing around that time
and that's just the biggest thing that i
i i got i got to be honest with you man
like normally i'm 100 with you guys
there's no way it's coming out but
there's so many people that's coming out
there and saying
don't listen to people this game's
coming out this year and i still think
it's a great chance it doesn't come out
this year but when you're constantly
having more than one because you have
one
one person that works for uh for the
saint monica come out and say it then
sony
tightens the leash on pr you know what
i'm saying nah you guys don't shut up
shut up you ain't talking
but they've had multiple so it kind of
makes me feel like sony's not tightening
that leash for a reason because sony
does expect it to come out this year
that doesn't mean it's coming out this
year but it is interesting how they're
going about it uh but we got to find all
the super chat from uh drawing tj he's
loving this topic god war is not coming
out this year sony needs something for
next year to look relevant wait i slow
down no no don't listen to her so you
are a hundred percent right on this i'm
not no no no i'm not mad at his opinion
i'm just the second half of that is that
you need something else to be relevant
y'all know uh spider-man's supposed to
come out in 2023 right spider-man 2.
right yeah yeah let's not do that listen
so let's not do that one everybody slow
down yes yeah spider-man going going on
do what it do let's
go saying that's one game yeah i i think
we can we can just okay also let's be
real here mm-hmm yeah they they they got
a gatlic gun and xbox about to hit them
with a spirit ball next year like
we'll see we'll see spider-man 2 in no
way shape or form is going to compare to
all the games dropping next year
you say that but this is insomniac we're
talking about so we can't let's not
sleep on it come on come on come on i
got a video out there you know they're
the most consistent ones over there over
there playstations oh it's not according
to medicare last year they won the
they won the the most consistent
metacritic scores no no no no what i'm
saying is
oh no we're talking about consistency i
just gave you facts well okay like well
we are talking about consistency just
like the coalition the most consistent
over for xbox they are it's it is you
know they drop it's gonna be good it's
gonna be good enough to carry them
through a generation i feel like
insomniac is gonna do that again i feel
like insomniac is gonna run
them through this generation then you
know the naughty dog cooking up to
cooking up but my point is this my point
is this
slow down
because we gotta we still gotta wait for
xbox we still got away regardless all
the acquisitions that were made we still
gotta tj don't slow down don't listen to
this oh man you you you spray all that
that that propaganda you want man
you could put that on channel six news i
still like it all right so we we gotta
we gotta move on from that is unless you
guys want to talk about uh this game you
know we uh actually
we can bring this up just relatively
thing since we're talking about 2022. we
might talk about playstation xbox a lot
but i i know i'm about to contradict
myself
and i know
see this is where you know i'm real i'm
admitting i'm about to contradict myself
i'm coming out on the stage and saying
i'm about to completely make myself look
a fool but nintendo's having a late year
and it does it seems like every month
they're adding on another game to make
that lit you're even more lit
uh i'm not gonna play the majority of
them i'm gonna be real with you i don't
care about the majority of their games
uh but i don't even care about kirby but
people love kirby uh
and i i've reviewed um
triangle strategy great game they're
having a good year i would honestly say
that they're having a better year than
the other platform holders at this point
you know we have to see how starfield
hits and we have to see how uh red fall
hits uh but you know what i've seen on
playstation the horizon forbidden west
and uh sifu they're definitely they
they're they've already spirit balling
them out of the room like nintendo is
they one thing you can really appreciate
for nintendo is they're carrying their
fan base and i've always appreciated
because they're like look
we get it you guys are trying to get
everyone talking to xbox and playstation
we only care about our people and i
always have to respect them for that
all right but that's the league who's
seen the leaks be honest not me i have
it
all right so there there's some leaks on
um
talking a little bit about
elder scrolls sticks
well you know i'll go ahead and share it
because i got this nice little share
feature hold up let me bring it up
and i what i think's interesting
technology
i know man
uh it's it's it's definitely a nice
little thing all right so let me see if
i could share these successfully
all right so we're sharing
this
this is what it's supposed to share okay
so i'm glad that i'm not the only one
that does that so i'm good
as you can see here
that
we see all of uh this little thing now i
want to read
these opening things here as you can see
there's there's quite a bit all right so
bethesda's
stuff i'm hearing on a nominal social
now keep in mind none of this is
confirmed but i think it's interesting
uh because i honestly feel like star
field is going to be a huge hit
but
the impact of elder scrolls 6 is going
to blow starfire out of the water
like it's ivan people think
that starfill being exclusive was very
important to the xbox brand wait to that
elder scrolls 6 hype starts it hasn't
started now but wait till it does let's
go ahead and start reading
but that's the stuff i'm hearing from an
anonymous source please take this with a
grant assault don't claim it as an
inside statement from me
i do want to point that maddie mr maddie
plays did confirm he's hearing similar
things so i think that validates these
rumors a little bit more and i'm not
saying they're true
let me put that out there i'm not saying
they're true
but i am saying that it's out there so
let's keep reading
pvp versus pvp slash e game and
development a roundhouse that may
surprise you uh for those of you i don't
think roundhouse has made a game am i
wrong that's the studio that's brand new
we ain't seen nothing from them yet
elder scrolls uh the elder scrolls six
is set in hammerfell so
people were wondering uh one of the
biggest things that people wonder when
it comes to the elder scrolls game is
where location it's going to be
because that is very important tamara is
a huge place and we've seen a lot of it
but there's some things that hasn't been
real
built on lore and i think it's really
interesting what's going on there uh
elder scrolls 6 will have a political
system
that's interesting
elder scrolls has always had
features and mechanics that was
political but this makes it seem like
they're going to build onto that and
make it more mainstream
betrayals marriage and factions matter
in the elder scrolls 6. for those who
don't know you could get married in
previous games uh i'm curious what they
mean by betrayals
because that that's that's an
interesting thing there what they mean
by betrayals uh
the
elder scrolls is in full development
early stages so clearly we're not going
to see this anytime soon but i want
people to know
it's in full production already so
probably two years i would say three
tops
probably three three years we'll see it
in three years uh target releases in
2025 2026 yeah three years exactly what
i just said
uh
uh bethesda game studio austin and metro
are working on spy team what is that
does anyone know what spy team is no sir
no well you know what
we got a little thing called search
that's right
but that's a re-ups on an unannounced
team called spy teams
i don't know what that is but you know
you guys could see it clearly um i guess
it's going to be some version of a game
they play i don't know uh mando mmo in
the
uh amanda uh the cinemax online uh
mandalorian people don't know that this
is supposed to be a mandalorian game and
the people that make elder scrolls
online is making this game
that's going to be interesting how you
guys feel about a mandalorian mmo how do
you think that can go let's let's let's
go around the the room for that hustle
how do you think amanda lauren is that a
hit or a miss would you try that what's
the mess for me because that's the star
wars that's the star wars thing right
yes yeah that's a mess for me yeah yeah
i mean it's just they did it sorry
blasphemy
what am i supposed to do here listen
listen one of the greatest supposed to
get with the times
but no what we should be talking about
is one of the greatest uh video game
franchises coming to pc and that's
uncharted for the legacy of thieves
collection coming uh june 20th according
to an epic games report anyway you know
what never mind never mind let me let me
stop let me let me stop let me let me
put my my playstation shield down for a
second this list of this gentleman came
i'm gonna be honest with you anybody
tells me
anything in regards to
take this with a grain of salt i
normally do when i normally just brush
it off now
earlier you said you know friend of the
show you said maddie was kind of on
board with this because he's heard
different things in the background right
hold up i'll show you right here
i would share identical information to
this a couple days ago about the future
bethesda project but i
uh but i too could not verify it or
validate of the source so i did not want
to post any of it
so uh mr maddie plays is hearing the
same
thing i haven't heard nothing related to
this but i have heard stuff about um
about star field i haven't heard nothing
that's on this
uh so so continue with your slider
hustle
yes yes yes i normally when people say
take it with a grain of salt i normally
do
i kind of want to see whatever in black
and white but
y'all dance had a lot more than me so i
kind of
i may suffer my stance on that a little
bit look the mandalorian stuff the star
wars stuff i think i tried to play
battlefront 2 which i think was made by
ea
and it just really wasn't my thing the
star wars i know a lot of people like
they're super big on that it's just not
my thing
it's nothing that yes sir nothing that
i'd be extremely excited about even amy
henning the former writer of uncharted
she's doing her own thing with star wars
and that's picking up a lot of steam i'm
not even excited for that either i like
uncharted
sorry got a 5 super chat from drawn tj i
gotta ask when did we get a new elder
scrolls online because the one we have
now is outdated i don't know um
i wouldn't have your hopes up too much
that they're moving on to the
mandalorian now i'm not gonna say that
they're gonna stop working on elder
scrolls online but to me if you're
putting your resources onto a new
project at least for the foreseeable
future
a lot of the resources is going to be in
the mandalorian and they're going to
have some go to the elder scrolls online
then again you know i don't know how
much money the elder scrolls online
makes and that is a very important thing
when it comes to these kind of talks
because if it's making a lot of money
they will put more resource behind to
keep it going so target shiny tell me if
you want a mandalorian mmo game i'm
curious to hear your opinion
well unfortunately i'm with hustle i
don't care about star wars look at all
this slander man sorry like after disney
after episode 8 i'm like this is dead to
me i don't care star wars can go away
i do not care one bit about it i gotta
drink my sorrows away wow man
all right i'm done with star wars
all right okay mega yeah
so so i so i hope that they got the same
energy for cold tour that's coming up
here
i'm 1000 dude sir okay okay i'm just i'm
just saying because you know sometimes
if people got that playstation shield
they usually you know they get they
usually could kind of do a 360 or do
something else they kind of hide it like
oh yeah but anyway that guy on that game
and i haven't played it yeah
but all right um no i'm i'm thoroughly
stoked i hope this is true but remember
there's been rumors about this whole
mandalorian situation for
ever since last year almost going back
to uh 2020 at the end of 2020
so um
during the first season of mandalorian
so that would be very interesting i
would love that
um me myself dude mmo
that that might be a little a little
much for me because there's just so much
to play now i mean accordingly you know
by that time when that game drops we're
going to get a full-fledged halo
infinite with what that's going to be
plus all the rest of the stuff that's
going to be coming out at that point in
time you know so
um
i just would hope it would be a
more of a you know a big huge budget
gain um kind of like what uh like what
the what ea did with star wars on their
end but uh but no just for that would be
cool now yeah that list is really
interesting um and and i i have a friend
that
uh loves elder scrolls online that's all
he really plays so that would be dope if
they would do something but if they are
going to be working on another mmo i i
agree with you addict like they would be
putting more of their uh time and
efforts into that into that new game
than they would go back to uh elder
scrolls online but
um yeah no i mean i it just looks like
this big thing is coming just coming
from there now
seeing the nxl stuff
uh
that would be hot because i am a big fan
of theirs um i'm late to the party with
with their games with the wasteland uh
series but man after playing uh
wasteland three and then i went back to
play uh wasteland two
man i love their work so and then on top
of that they got a new game that's
supposed to be coming out like a
steampunk futuristic type of game kind
of like on the cyberpunk type of
wavelength so
i'm i'm all in for it but yeah
everything else and then i uh quake
reboot i know that there'll be a lot of
people that's happy about that so
um this list looks really really solid
if it is true but yeah but like you said
all hill the king skyrim yeah
that's everything we'll go ahead and
talk a little bit about a quake reboot
it's interesting because
it does look like they're that um idea
is done with doom
so if they are done with them because
for those of you that didn't play the
expansions it kind of like
settled all the stuff that's happening
in the doom universe
so i'm kind of curious if they are truly
do done with them maybe they'll do
something else or cause some kind of
spin off but if they are done with doom
what is next and i feel like
quake screams id like screams it
and if there is an i uh if there is
talks about a reboot of quake
in the works at bethesda software
studios i don't see anyone else but id
being the perfect people to make that
uh so it would be interesting well what
will you guys start with hardy uh hardy
um
how do you feel about a quake i know you
were hating on
mandalorian earlier but surely there's
quake love in you
yeah i'm not like
excited to all i haven't but it's uh it
does sound good uh if they can do what
they did with um with you know the
recent doom and dew maternal uh that
could be a very good compelling uh you
know thing to do with quake so uh sure
that that sounds like a pretty
interesting thing to do why not
what about hustle and motive now keep in
mind hustle
it's gonna be an xbox exclusive it's not
being on your playstation how do you
feel about that
i mean yeah i mean we're talking quake
um that's one of the first games i
learned like how to
not fully play but this is one of the
first games i learned how to play it on
pc because it's only mouse and keyboard
on there and that doesn't use it to its
full capabilities the mouse and keyboard
portion of it but
it's cool it's cool like it's you know
quick little shoot em up bang bang like
i like it i like it um
i'm okay with that i'm mine with that um
i kind of feel like they need something
else in regards to like another first
person shooter because you know sadly
halo isn't performing the way that it
should be performing right now so
something new like that and a classic ip
like that coming back that that would be
dope
that would be like super dope uh and fun
to have i'm looking over this list right
look the star wars thing is a star wars
thing i'm just not a big
i just can't
it ain't really nothing for me to get
into uh
is that
it is that yeah is that really it
looks like yeah that's like that's
really it but
it's cool i mean you know for for me i
mean it doesn't like to come on
the world that hears about a mandalorian
mmo
listen listen i i tried getting into
star wars man it just wasn't it was
never my thing like even back in the day
you know i'm a retro head even back in
the day when i tried to play like the
empire strikes back and all this stuff
on super nintendo just wasn't yeah
it's cool it's cause it's cool they it's
cool that you know i don't want to say
bury it because i don't want to like
nobody else to lose out on that
experience but
i'm good like they won't get my little
ten dollars or
whatever it is
if i hear the word uh from from
from hustle man it's going to be
devastating to my mental state all right
so we got another five uh five dollar
super chat from uh
uh from drawing tj jaiden heart target
harjeet
that right harji did i get it hardy
that's right why you got to do star wars
like that
are you going to you're going to answer
that
i didn't yet it's uh it's simple i
didn't disney did
oh that's right oh he didn't disney did
interesting they killed it it's their
fault
then we got then we got a member chat uh
uh we got lord myra hoof with uh he sent
a message uh he's been a member for for
eight months he said jason confirmed an
xbox reset era form
that uh pretty much that these leaks are
not true now look normally i 100
always agree with most of the things
that jason said because he's got a
pretty good accurate record
but i do know that
bethesda you sometimes it's his
kryptonite so
um
i don't know how realistically because
he got banned from there a long time ago
obviously some people could be telling
him stuff but a lot of this stuff i feel
like
if a bunch of people are saying it's
happening and they're hearing it's
happening but just jason ronald says no
now obviously jason ronald could be
could be right but you know
we got to see more in terms of what's
going on and we can't just not not talk
about it jason schrei could easily be
right but these are some big stuff going
on man like elder scrolls is a huge
franchise that is probably microsoft's
most popular franchise when uh that they
own currently is elder scrolls yeah uh
you know i think that eclipses halo
these days
if we haven't seen one since 2011 i
think it has more of a
of a name in gamers than something like
halo
i ain't gonna go that far yeah i'm gonna
go that far no
no i'm gonna start it
i think meg is right because like it's
just too big a name like halo defined
the the dude bro shooter it just like so
that is just a whole genre that people
know yeah elder scrolls is in the show
that's what i was gonna say yeah yeah
yeah
it's known as the game
they're not gonna be a skyrim tv show
yeah but even if
you don't mean
halo was a cultural phenomenon because
people went and bought xboxes just to
play that game right so it was just the
thing i think it really is out there at
this point i'm okay with anyone making
anything as long as that paramore yeah i
mean the one that's going to beat them
call of duty right well the call of duty
will be that
they butchered haters so much i don't
even think i want to pronounce their
name right
so
come on i'm just joking man i'm just
joking calm down
all right we're gonna go ahead and uh
you know start closing these out you
guys are trying to get us up in here out
quick as possible because i know people
got lives man people got lives so the
first one was gonna start with it's hard
gut shanin where can people find you at
man i know you don't got a twitter nope
and we we gotta fix that because look
man we we are out
like i'm willing to come outside the
castle known as twitter to show you
where the door is you got to walk
through it though but but i will warn
you parky once you walk in that castle
door they're going to lock that [ __ ]
right when you pass those doors so when
you leave you can't you when you come in
you cannot leave
where can people find you uh i'll put in
my the link to my channel uh you can go
there and of course game on daily uh so
uh i'm often on the uh game on daily go
live show
um and i'll be putting up videos on on
the
game on daily youtube channel as well
uh so that's where you can find me
where uh what kind of content you make
on your youtube channel
um in general as i said in the beginning
it's basically um i look at things in an
analysis format i don't really look at
like the sort of day-to-day news i try
to analyze the industry as a whole so
that's kind of more of my content
okay so um definitely go you put put
that in the chat uh once or twice more
so people can really see
k-mega
what up what up what up what up what wha
what's going on okay megan uh man
nothing other than my wife over here uh
she picked me up like she's like like
normally that don't happen but she was
over here hit me up and i was like oh my
goodness what's happening okay
she's like you're not supposed to be on
a podcast this time of day she did say
that she was like what what's going on
what she's like uh because she called
and i didn't see the call and then she
was like hey i said i'm gonna you know
what it is
she hurts
she heard that halo
the halo positivity and she on that
floor correcting you you know what she
likes the halo tv show you know so not
in my story my story she doesn't stuff
so so how we do it we we wait till we
wait till the halo show comes out and
then we both watch moon night and halo
together so you know any way to try to
get into the gaming space as much as i
can so you know it's all good but yeah
um i appreciate you having me come on i
apologize that i was late man you know
gotta take care got to do life things uh
take care of business but man i do
appreciate the invite man definitely uh
look forward to
uh you having me come back again uh
definitely gotta get you come on grg
which is a podcast that i do um it's on
friday nights 8 p.m i want to put the
link up
uh let's see oh oh oh okay okay i
appreciate that man thank you thank you
thank you appreciate it brother um and i
got to get you back on too man that was
a that was a really fun show having you
on and now knowing your true colors i'm
really going to harass you when you come
over there so
uh
don't worry i think it's um it's me and
um well what's the young lady's name oh
my gosh i blanked on her name just that
quick robbs roberts
oh yeah okay oh yeah yeah cause she
she's a nintendo and a playstation fan
so yeah no i got back up i'm starting
yeah yo you definitely got back up and
then these you sometimes jump on because
that's a whole girl so i you know so ham
solo is in the interest me and lord
bless
but thank you guys uh really appreciate
it but uh yeah come check out the grg
podcast every friday night 8 pm central
uh 9 p.m eastern 6 p.m pacific and i
think it's 2 a.m gmt time
um yeah i know and i've had a couple of
guys overseas to come through man uh uh
grendel yeah he came over man it was
like
two and he and we had a long podcast it
was like three hours and it was like
five o'clock in the morning i said man
you a champion thank you so much so i
was afraid to ask him if you want to cut
back on again for that but uh yeah then
also do the next podcast which is on um
xbox 448 channel that is going to be
tomorrow night on thursdays at 7 pm
uh so check that out and then i do a
thing on sunday nights called fight
night sunday man where i play all
different types of fighters uh anybody
is welcome to come and join um
we had a really crazy session of killer
instinct it was amazing and uh yeah uh
all the stuff i do devon the gamer as
well we do that every other week uh with
me and my boy the don and uh that's on
my channel as well so man yeah just come
and follow me and check me out on
twitter at kmega4 man it's a blessing
thank you
what's going on hustle what's
what you doing man i see you making that
uh that that teenage mutant ninja turtle
content you know they need any more of
that coming along i will say that we are
going to uh try to get a little bit of
that teenage mutant ninja turtle uh
co-op thing going on now correct me if
i'm wrong it's only two player online
correct
i
actually don't know so i'm hearing i'm
hearing this drop-in dropout co-op but i
also heard from just like different
videos that i've been like watching it's
somebody said it was full played co-op i
don't really know about that but there
is a game informer interview with um
tribute emu and um and i guess
nickelodeon took part in this they got a
whole like layout of it i don't have
gamestop no more so i mean i don't have
a gaming forum no more but i gotta
re-sign up for cause i got the the
gamestop pro pass thing so i just got a
lot back on i'm gonna do some research
into that and um you actually will see
another video after the kingdom hearts
one about everything that we know so far
so i am doing research on that as we
speak
they made it seem like it was four
player co-op though they made it seem
like that and um
these are the same people who was um who
did uh streets of rage four
and if y'all know if you know you know
but there was a workaround if you wanted
to uh do the things for streets and rage
for if you wanted to play online you
just had to do like remote play so
depending like this if you had everybody
on the east coast like we all on the
east coast we can run that no problem um
friend of the show friends of the show
erica aircraft for the win and uh drone
pixel drenizin overseas and erica's out
on the west side they actually played
the streets of rage and they ran pretty
fine on their live stream so
you know i'm hoping you know keep my
fingers crossed for the same thing twice
so i'm working on that um i'm doing the
kingdom hearts thing and um
that's about it for now um i got one
other special thing but i'm not gonna
say too much about that right now i'm
gonna keep keep y'all waiting so just
follow me wherever hustling motivate all
over the place and if you see me online
and if you see me playing halo infinite
please help me
[Laughter]
i'm not asking for much just just come
carry me the victory we will be all
right i want to thank our guests for
joining us hargie cheney
hockey i'm glad you're in the space but
you got to get on twitter though all
right look look this that's what i do
when i get on twitter because i'm mr
positive
follow everybody who i follow and you'll
be straight
all the other stuff that you'll see on
the joint
i don't see none of that so i don't know
what's going on i don't see none of that
um
okay mega yeah i'll be back on the show
man i'm gonna be back on your show you
know nice you know playstation lumps
that's what i'm end up giving you but
nice it's cool man it's cool
that's cool thank y'all thank you for
coming we really appreciate y'all
we got a five dollar super chat from
drawn tj hope you guys are having a
great day just wanted to show support
appreciate thank you thank you tj
uh everyone that you know even if you
didn't super chat if you liked the
podcast definitely hit that like button
i'd love to see that like button go as
high as possible uh you know you chatted
uh it's easier to bounce off of people
than it is to uh you guys keep the
people in that chat man sometimes some
of you argue with each other and that's
perfectly fine just keep it respectful
one thing i want to say is my personal
youtube channel will be restructuring
here soon i'll probably say that on iop
because i'm still
getting the the fine tooth how exactly i
want to do it uh so we'll be i'll be
explaining how that's going to happen
sunday uh now i can't guarantee this is
going to happen but i am planning next
week
to have hip-hop gamer and king david on
uh right now i ain't got the yes from
either one of them
you know yo we'll see if i'm able to get
that happen
i'm gonna just sit back and let them go
uh because it's gonna be a fun little
time man i'm gonna i'm gonna make a
console warrior because because that's
what we do best around here you know we
have fun huh can i can i say one more
thing before we go yes
now you know i normally you know and i
got this shout out to love on one game
and i actually got this idea from peep
game which is a podcast with dallas man
and baron j67 we gotta have them on too
attic we got we definitely gotta have
them on at some point um check out big
cloud he is doing a one-on-one interview
with tony polanco over there from the
throwdown podcast
yeah let's go ahead and show him our
support man [ __ ] i'm doing it right now
uh no he will be doing it in a half an
hour so i'm gonna link the channel now
shout out to big clown man yeah he's
been on grg man good dude good dude yeah
one of the realest dudes around this
story he's you know some behind the
scenes stuff
he literally like helped me with like my
youtube banner and and just a lot of
other stuff behind the scenes man him
blaze that's my dundo like shout out to
them over there solid casting they doing
their thing but uh let's go ahead and
support uh cloud yeah um
thank y'all let's get them lights up to
like 1 30 before we get up out of here
please it's 164 y'all i can see you i
see y'all please hit the like button
please hit the like button and um just
thank thank y'all man just the support
is like overwhelming uh like hargee like
you i i came from the comments section
too and i'm just trying to do my thing i
know how hard it is but um nah it's it's
cool thank thank y'all both for joining
us man i got i always have fun it was an
honor man no doubt no doubt
no doubt man
no doubt
all right and
like i said man definitely go follow
okay megan and haruki shani good good
good content over there man go follow
those you can't follow him he don't get
on twitter remember
his youtubers in there
oh oh oh okay okay hold on where is it
so i can go follow him oh hold on i'll
bring it back up hey
all right oh that's it i got it i got it
right now i'm following right here all
right
oh yeah you guys are funny funny funny
fellas over here all right but i
appreciate it for coming back we'll be
back next week hopefully it will be
with with king david off the iop and hip
hop gamer now uh it just depends on what
hip hop can do king usually if i give
him a couple days heads up he'll be able
to show uh
and i'm very curious because the last
time we had both of them on is a very
interesting show but you know i
appreciate it for coming through and
until next week this is the attic show
and we out
peace